I've encountered a vergence force you
refer to the prophecy of the one who
will bring balance to the force
darkness rises hey everybody hopefully
you've had a chance to see the movie at
least once this is going to be my video
addressing episode 9 things all the
hanging plot threads and the larger
themes of the new trilogy and how
they're gonna have to wrap everything up
and where they might hit from there and
the really cool thing is is that JJ
Abrams just pitched the initial story or
at least the idea of episode 9 to Disney
CEO Bob Iger and they gave the film a
working title the working title for
episode 8 was space bear I'll explain
what that means in a second but episode
9 is just being called Black Diamond
right now so that evokes some very
specific imagery like you're all
thinking about the dark saber right now
but just remember that the working title
doesn't always mean something about the
story or the characters or have any real
relevance to the film itself so just to
give you an example that Rian Johnson
said that space bear was actually a joke
that they said offhandedly behind the
scenes while they were figuring the
story out so there is no actual space
bear in the movie it's not an easter egg
for anything they just said that there
was this story situation that they had
to get the characters out of they didn't
know how they were gonna solve it so
they joked that a space bear would fly
in and save everyone but if you are new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get everything I'm even doing an IMAX
ticket giveaway that I'll explain at the
end of the video it's just because I
forgot to say it earlier in the video
careful for spoilers for episode 8
because we'll be talking about very
specific plot points number 10 minimum
one-year time jump to allow for more
recognizable Empire to rise to power
like the new Empire whatever they're
going to call it because it's still
called the first order right now and
then that same duration of time to allow
the rebellion to replenish their
supplies because they're sort of calling
themselves the new rebellion now whereas
they used to be just the resistance but
number 9 in this time period because
kylo Ren is effectively unchallenged
there's no resistance to combat the
first order they will have effectively
taken over it is settled into his role
as supreme leader because he doesn't
spend that much time as actual supreme
leader during the movie he just flies
down to the
of crate has everybody blast luke
skywalker's for spirit then flies away
after he fails to kill everyone
but number 8 that time jump will also
allow you to explain what happens to
Leia because Carrie Fisher passed away
so they could even begin the opening
crawl with giant capital letters general
solo is dead but her tireless work to
replenish the rebellion against the
first order has been successful and they
go into a couple of sentences
explanation for why there's a new
rebellion why they have more ships and
how everyone was inspired by her and she
died peacefully paving the way for Poe
Dameron to become a more balanced leader
so it just seems like they're setting
him up to take more of a leadership role
in the next film but because both of
these forces are rising darkness rises
and light to meet it so you have two
different Jedi rising up but you also
have two different fleets rising up
there is an actual star war that happens
it's not like one group of people chase
the other group of people across the
galaxy you have a genuine giant space
battle but number six getting into more
to the Jedi stuff Rey constructs a new
lightsaber out of the pieces of Anakin
Skywalker's lightsaber there's a Kyber
crystal that was seen clearly at the end
of the film so she has all the pieces
that she needs but she also has the Jedi
books which probably have more
instructions about how to modify
lightsabers and because she favors the
staff also big prediction it will be a
double bladed lightsaber that may or may
not be a different color there were a
lot of you that we're asking me
questions about the specific color of
Anakin's crystal in that lightsaber
because as it was exposed it looked
white so naturally a lot of you were
wondering if that means that Raisa
lightsaber is going to be white just
like a sokka's lightsaber because
technically ahsoka left the Jedi Order
and crystals are attuned to Jedi they
played a little bit with the lure of
Kyber crystals in the meaning of the
different colors but for the most part I
don't think they're gonna be a lot of
changes in the actual hue of the
lightsaber I think it's just going to be
double bladed and if anything it would
be white I don't think it's gonna be
yellow or purple samuel l.jackson style
I don't think they're gonna get too
crazy with colors but number five kylo
Ren talking about his downfall
so he's shown he's fixated on things
like daddy issues he has the biggest
daddy issue
of anybody else in this film Rey has
some minor daddy issues because she
wants to know who her parents are so she
starts to put that on Luke
kylo Ren even calls her out on a little
bit he goes crazy when he sees the
Millennium Falcon blasts that piece of
garbage out of the sky he also knew that
Ray was on it so like luke skywalker
says kill me and i'll be with you
forever
just like your father he's lashing out
against his father anytime he sees the
Millennium Falcon he goes crazy but he's
also lashing out against Rey because of
her rejection of him he's myopically
fixated on people and things to the
detriment of logic and that's going to
be his ultimate downfall
along with his rivalry with Huck's who
we'll talk about in a second but number
four a pretty easy one to predict Luke
Skywalker will return as a force ghost
multiple times wants to give Rey advice
when she desperately needs it tell some
jokes yoda style because Luke told a lot
of jokes during last Jedi but I think
we're also all expecting some sort of
mirror moment for the end of Return of
the Jedi where you have multiple force
ghosts staring at Rey as Luke used to be
the future of the force in the galaxy
all their hope for the future was rested
in him and they wanted to show him how
proud they were of him I think there'll
be a similar type moment for Rey's
character at the end of the trilogy with
a slight twist the people that show up
during that force ghost parade I think
will just be a little bit different like
in the original one it was Anakin Yoda
and obi-wan Kenobi so there's been a lot
of question about who can become force
ghost and there's been a lot of time
spent developing that in Cannon so you
have qui-gon who was the first person to
learn how to do it he passed that on to
Yoda then Yoda passed it on to obi-wan
Kenobi presumably obi-wan Kenobi showed
up and passed that on to Luke so that's
how Luke learned how to become a force
ghost but at the moment I'm kind of
50/50 on this but the way they bend the
rules of the force for these movies in
service of really big WTF moments number
three it's also possible that they'll
allow Leia to show up as a force ghost
at the very end because she seemed
relatively powerful when she OTO used
the force to get herself out of the
vacuum of space number two this is a
pretty easy slam-dunk kylo Ren ray
lightsaber fight rematch
in a slight twist on the return of the
Jedi idea I do believe there's gonna be
hopeful spin and I'll explain why in a
second that because the Emperor of this
trilogy the Snoke character is already
dead
hugs will ascend to the position of most
hateable character so kylo Ren is being
positioned as the main villain of the
third film but ultimately I think that
Rey will balance him out there'll be
some balance in the force paving the way
for Huck's to be the standard villain
that you punch in the face because that
seems to be his role he's either used
for slapstick comedy or as a straight-up
Nazi so there's no redemption for his
character he's either gonna die in a
hilarious way or in a twist on the
Emperor's throne room battle but not a
direct reference to that because they
kind of already did that moment during
last Jedi but number one here's a real
big one about kylo Ren and rain the
future of the Jedi Order
so darkness rises light to meet it it's
all about balance in the force remember
that idea but also the idea that these
new movies are very clearly trying to
move past the idea of Skywalker's in
skywalker blood luke even makes a joke
about mighty skywalker blood so even if
kylo ren crawls out of this trilogy
alive he father's no children in there
are effectively no more Skywalker's
depending on how you look at it there
could be some mystery Luke children out
there Mark Hamill said that he wrote
himself a non canonical version of
Luke's backstory where he had a wife
that died so there could always be a
child out there somewhere that they
talked about in the expanded universe
and the novels or something like that
but I'm just not expecting them to
continue with the idea of Skywalker's in
the films beyond the idea of force
ghosts so there will always be Skywalker
stuff in the Star Wars universe but I
think that largely will flow through
Luke Skywalker's force ghost character
as he gives advice to Rey and whatever
her future is after episode 9 so the
reason why I don't think it's ultimately
raised destiny to kill kylo Ren unless
she's planning on dying too is because
replacing darkness with light is not
balance balance is darkness and light
coexisting at the same time luke's
conversation with rey about the darkside
cave on auch - is exactly like snoke's
conversation it exists on the island
Emel taneous li with all the light side
of the force so the whole idea of
darkness rising and light to meet it is
is that they're both meant to be two
sides of one character in that character
is the force itself the thing that binds
all life in the galaxy so ultimately
that sounds like a more hopeful ending
even though there's a lot of WTF battles
that have to happen before that can go
down so let me know in the comments the
whole idea of balancing the force not
replacing darkness with light what do
you think the future of the movies are
how do you think the kylo Ren and Rey's
story is going to end congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner 90 - please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details
I'll just announce a new winner the next
time I post a new Star Wars video you
can click here for all my Easter eggs
and you can click here for my top 10 WTF
questions after the end of the film
thank you so much for watching everybody
to stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight